Edward is in New York City hi Edward how
are you hi how's it going better than I
deserve what's up so I just want to try
to summarize it I just had a big change
in my life I found out my girlfriend was
pregnant which was pretty exciting and
then a couple months after that I found
out that it's twins okay
it went from pretty exciting to know I'm
kind of scared
terrified yeah yeah I have a car loan
that got me worried I have two years
left on the financing plan
I just wanted to figure out if I should
get rid of the car or if I could hunker
down and budget a bit better yeah what
do you owe on it total I owe seventeen
and what is your household income
I am currently with both my jobs making
63 to 65 both jobs are hourly and my
girlfriend as is around 25 okay
all right cool all right when y'all
getting married once we get that down a
bit more because she's got a ton in
student loans so I was hoping I don't
know I don't you have twins I don't know
what debt matters yeah I mean you're
already doing everything married people
do except being married and so yeah I
would encourage you to do that because
it's going to stabilize everything
illegally and relationally and allow you
guys to focus on this I think you can
keep the car you can work it through and
get it paid down especially if it works
for twins it's a good solid vehicle and
if that's your only debt you can plow
your way through this I'm encouraged to
get married immediately
you don't have to have a you know get
out of debt thing you have babies it's
like you know this is this is an
important thing and so let's stabilize
this household let's get things moving
in the right direction and let's get
these debts paid off as soon as possible
is this car paid off so good question
star thank you for calling in this is
the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]